[Musik]
das parkett ist platin blm unic hallo
herr willkommens vorlesungen der über
die philosophie heute werden wir
weiterhin klar vorne und besprechen und
zwar den zweiten teil wo wir die
bekannte bildung theorie von einem
nächstes das heißt wieder erkenntnis
wieder erinnerung erleben und
diskutieren werden können alle ist es
besser wenn ich also ich habe die die
grüne stift mitgenommen weil es zu
meinem politischen
aber ich weiß nicht ist das ist das
besser zu lesen oder ist das was sie
lesen was soll dann schreibe ich mit dem
roten stift schade weil das dann
irgendwie fliegt was wie weihnachten und
das im sommersemester
ich hatte letzte woche eines schwarzen
stift aber ich glaube das ist noch in
der jacke die ich letzte woche an hatte
auf jeden fall wieder mhh von dem was
wir letzte woche gesprochen haben
wir haben die erste hälfte des rennens
besprochen und zwar die passagen wo man
immer wieder versucht zu definieren also
als die tugend und er versucht mehrmals
die tuben zu definieren um sorgt diese
befriedigen weil also die die idee ist
man wollte wissen ob die tugend leer ist
und solche die es hat gleich gesagt das
kann ich nicht sagen weil ich nicht weiß
was die tugend ist aber du weißt es
wahrscheinlich leute von gears gelernt
hast was sie sein und dann versucht man
immer wieder das zu definieren und hat
immer weniger also mit immer weniger
zuversichtlich dass er das wirklich
machen kann
und nachdem er vier mal widerlegt wird
also das heißt sollte dies zeigt vier
mal dass eine definitionen nicht
tauglich sind
sagte meenen am ende sorgt ist wie ein
stachelrochen du du beißt mich oder du
wirst mich und ich kann nichts fühlen
also er kann sagt kann nichts kannst du
nicht bewegen und dann sagt sollte dies
also der sagt was lustiges wie oft er
sagt du bist ein schöner mann und
deswegen hast du ein vergleich für mich
erfunden damit ich dich mit irgendwas
vergleiche weil dann würde ich dann
würde er nicht nennen und mit was ganz
schönes vergleichen dass die idee aber
er gibt zu dass er einen stark wochen
wie ein stark betroffen ist aber nur ein
slogan der sich selbst auch paralysiert
weil er auch nicht weiß was er machen
soll
es gibt eine stelle in einem anderen
dialog wo er ein ein anderes beispiel
oder vergleich gibt was sich ganz schön
finde dass also diese diese unfähigkeit
fragen zu beantworten dass es wie gähnen
also wenn einer games dann fangen alle
andere in der anwesenheit anzugehen
das ist ein beispiel davon warum
plattform so toll ist
also ist wirklich sehr anschaulich
es macht auf jeden fall das soll alles
das sind zurück ins nahe bringen
diese situation der akkorde zu verstehen
und wie ich letzte woche gesagt habe ist
ab oder ein zustand wo man buchstäblich
nicht weitergehen kann oder keine
mitteln hat womit man weitergehen kann
das später in der philosophie zum
beispiel bei al assad ließ bekommt alle
april eine technische bedeutung
das heißt so was wie ein puzzle putzer
ist kein deutsches wort ein paar
wirklich und sehr falsch irgendwie also
ein problem problem ist schwierig weil
es gibt auch dieses griechischen
probleme probleme aber es ist ein
problem oder eine schwierige frage
vielleicht die man stellt um die frage
dann zu lösen und fortschritt in der
presse hieß machen also diese idee dass
philosophie in arborea anfangen muss das
läuft dann in etwas hinein und dann
weiter durch die geschichte der flößerei
aber jetzt zeigt es mehr ein problem zu
sein also das ist eigentlich eine
beklagen
von seiten von der seite - dass er
sozusagen jetzt mit leeren händen
dasteht nicht weitergehen kann und auch
wie ich letzte woche gesagt habe könnte
man bei den sogenannten sokratischen
dialogen jetzt vorstellen dass man
schluss hätte also das wäre praktisch
die die letzte seite des dialogs vor
kritisiert würde sagen so was wie ja wir
wissen nicht was wir sagen sondern aber
wir sollen weiter suchen aber das
problem liegt auf der hand das problem
wie sollen wir jetzt weiter suchen wenn
wir mit leeren händen dastehen
also wie man könnte sagen die frage ist
jetzt wie kommt man aus der abwehr
heraus um irgendetwas zu entdecken
und wenn es wirklich stimmt dass man
eine so genannte traditionelle dialog
ist dann zum teil weil platon jetzt
nichts damit zufrieden ist dass er hier
bleibt stehen bleibt sondern er will was
vorschlagen um zu erläutern wie man
trotzdem fortschritt machen könnte das
ist nicht unbedingt eine kritik an
socket ich mein man könnte das als einen
kritik wahrnehmen wenn man denkt ja okay
also etwas platt um sagen will es sagte
thies du was ganz gut also bevor sie
dich umgebracht haben was du kannst gut
mit falsche meinung zu entdeckende und
endlos bloßen contest anderen leute
zeigen dass sie kein wissen besitzen
aber was weiß wo du nicht sehr gut bist
ist positive verlässlich philosophische
theorien zu entwickeln
das passt nicht unbedingt sehr gut zu
anderen themen die wir in den dialogen
ist es in dem memo finden
typisch sokratische thesen die wir heute
noch bestreiten werden aber methodisch
gesehen könnte man das als eine kritik
sorgte dies gegenüber verstehen
andererseits
man man könnt ihr auch denken er ist es
sehr wichtig wenn wir fortschritte
machen wollen dass wir mit dieser
sokratischen methode anfangen wo wir
handeln leute zeigen dass sie keine
ahnung haben weil es so lang dass sie
glauben dass sie glauben dass sie wissen
solange sie zu wissen glauben zu wissen
was zum beispiel die tugend ist wenn sie
keinen fortschritt machen wenn sie unter
den eindruck sind dass ihre falsche
meinungen schon wissen anbieten
also man könnte sagen sie fangen hier
mit falschen meinung an und dann durch
sokratische die sokratischen methode
dieses abfragen
reichen sie april und das ist unwissen
aber bewusst hierher hat man wissen aber
nichts gewusst
und das ist das sagen was sie zu bieten
hat
dann brauchen wir eine neue methode um
wissen zu erreichen
nur das so erwerben und dieser schritt
ist natürlich mein auch wenn solche die
diese diesen schritt mit anbietet das
heißt nicht dass dieser schritt
unbedeutend ist das ist ja wichtig sogar
die thematisierung dieses problems wird
dann betont mit dem nec mit der nächsten
passage die ich nur kurz erwähnt habe
und das ist das sogenannte non paradox
paradox ist übrigens ein griechisches
wort para heißt gegen und doxa ist das
wort was sich dauernd als meinung
übersetzte also glaube oder überzeugung
so was also ein paradoxon ist was das
man nicht glauben kann
verständlich also dass gegen die glauben
oder gegen die meinung im allgemeinen
könnte man sagen dass es dass das ist
ein argument was zeigt dass deine
überzeugung nicht stimmen kann oder so
was also im grunde genommen ist ein
paradox das könnte ein also es kann
paradox sein weil es einfach unglaublich
ist aber man sieht nicht warum das nicht
stimmt so dass oft aber ist ein paradox
ein paradox in der philosophie ist wenn
man irgendwie zeigen kann dass pay und
nicht pay beide stimmen also das pay und
nicht bbva sind das ist natürlich
schlecht also zum beispiel wenn ich
zeigen kann dass mein lieblingsprojekt
das paradox aller zeiten
ist dieser satz ist falsch oder ich lüge
jetzt es ist so genannten meyer paradox
paradox wenn dieser satz war ist dann
ist der satz falsch wenn das falsch ist
dann ist das als wahr und es gibt
zahlreiche versuche hinter dieses
paradox lösen
ob - paradox ein paar dutzend dieser
sind in diesem sinne
wer ist ist nicht so klar wahrscheinlich
nichts
man sieht es oft als paradox beschrieben
aber immer männern eigentlich zeigen
will ist nichts was nicht passt ein
mögliches also nicht das psp
beide stimmen sondern nur was sehr
überraschendes nämlich dass man mit
lernen nichts lernen kann also man kann
kein wissen erwerben
und ich habe die passage mitgebracht
vielleicht aus den männern und sorgt
hier ist noch da wollen sie das wäre
wäre das dieses mal habe ich das leider
nicht auf papier
wir wollen sie tauschen der letzte wer
war aktiv
letzte woche hat er wissen lassen zog
ots also sie fangen an als männer
einzige geschaffen wird
nichts was dir vorstellen
wir brauchen personen beträgt jetzt
daran lassen dass dieses ist was wir
nicht gestehen dass ich dann siehst du
dich was für einen schweizer zu werben
das ist ein nicht
die nacht hinein noch dass er für nicht
weil das weiß er was dürfte er wohl
nicht
gut also dass ist die berühmte stelle
mit den männern paradox mehrere
bemerkungen so der passage erstens
beschreibt socke diese männer und das
argument als ein streit satz die das
griechische ist dass das touristisch sei
also eher deftig ist ein plausibles aber
jeder führen das argument also man hat
den eindruck davon dass man gewinnt man
den eindruck dass solche sachen will
dein argument ist ein scheinargument
also es scheint markt ein argument das
lernen unmöglich ist aber oder das
untersucht das ist wenn wir sagen
untersuchungen ist unmöglich
aber das stimmt doch nichts und ich kann
hoffentlich zeigen warum es nicht stimmt
also es praktisch eine analyse oder
diagnose eines fehlers anbieten um zu
zeigen warum dieser streit satz nichts
gelte gäste eine bemerkung zweite
bemerken ist dass sockel kies des
argument umformuliert damit es viel
schärfer ist weil man uns sagt wie wirst
du uns das untersuchen was was du nicht
weisst denn als die beschaffen heißt du
deine untersuchen hier weil irgendwas
von dem nichts weiß dir vorstellen
oder wie wirst du wenn du es auch noch
so gut treffe dann müssen dass dieses
sei was du nicht kennst also die die
formulierung bei männern klingt mehr wie
ich soll jemanden suchen und ich werde
ihn nicht wiedererkennen wenn ich es
ihnen nicht schon kenne
es ist die zweite hälfte aber sorgt
dieses polit ist ein bisschen anders
er ist sagt es ist ein mensch menschen
unmöglich weder das was er weiß noch das
was er nicht weiß zu untersuchen
denn das was er weiß dürfte ja wohl
nicht untersuchen
denn er weiß es ja und das sagt man gar
nichts und dann ist das das problem was
man schon erwähnt ist ein bisschen
anders
er sagt und es bedarf dürfen keine
untersuchen ebenso wenig was er nicht
weiß denn er weiß ja nicht was
untersuchen sollen also dass nicht
wieder erkennen dass das problem besteht
das problem besteht nicht in der
unfähigkeit irgendwas zu erkennen wenn
man sie wenn man es zwölf zu sagen oder
begegnet das problem ist wie fange ich
an
ja und das entspricht mehr
diesen zustand der abonniert
also ich werde mich auf solche dieser
version des paradoxon konzentrieren
also ich hab keinen
also sokratische version des arguments
ist folgendes entweder also ich will
untersuchen und zum beispiel die tugend
entweder weiß ich schon weiß nicht ob
das idiomatisch ist auf deutsch
ob ich weiß also ein bisschen komisch
aber es funktioniert dafür mindestens
und auf englisch noch wichtiger also ein
der op das kann ein objekt nicht
das sind die zwei möglichkeiten wenn ich
schon weiß dann ist untersuchen
unmöglich aber unmöglich heißt und nötig
es gibt keinen bedarf dafür
während hier untersuchung möglich ist
warum werde untersuchung unmöglich wenn
ich nicht dass das ist anscheinend die
mine das ist nämlich an nicht so
kontrovers
also ich bin zum beispiel ex werks in
der atomphysik und ich weiß schon alles
was zu wissen ist über atomphysik dann
müsste ich marathon für sich nicht mehr
erforschen angenommen weiß alles was du
wissen ist ja meine erforschung oder
untersuchungen setzt voraus dass sich
irgend was bis jetzt noch nicht weiß was
ich herausfinde also das ist nicht so
kontrovers aber da ist deutschland
scheint sehr kontrovers sein oder
also warum werde das plausibel dass
untersuchung unmöglich ist wenn ich kein
wissen besitze man würde denken erst
recht muss ich dann eine untersuchung
unternehmen ja
wenn dir das doch nicht nur 13
also dass es nicht existiert könnte ich
nichts nicht existierendes sachen
erforschen zum beispiel ein einhorn
also ich weiss vielleicht weiß ich nicht
ob es ein herner gibt oder nicht aber
ich weiß mehrere sachen über 100 zum
beispiel dass sie gern gras essen und
dass sie an auch die die haben irgendwas
mit jungen frauen
weil eine interesse an jungen frauen
haben die einhörner und ich kenne ich
weiß sehr viel über andere wesen die
auch interesse an jungen frauen habe und
dass sie eigentlich also dass meine
stimme zu aber ich weiß nicht ob das
unbedingt mit existenz zu tun hat war es
scheint er sich dass ich das nicht
existierende oder das möglich nicht
existierende auch erforschen
wurde vielleicht sogar beides vielleicht
weiß ich nicht ob es gibt und ich weiß
aber auch überhaupt nichts wie es
beschaffen ist und nicht weit also keine
informationen vorhanden
das haben wir letzte woche auch gesagt
deswegen habe ich gesagt leere hände und
das ist angeblich der zustand der
abonnieren
also ich bin sozusagen mittellos dasteht
ohne irgendwelche hilfe oder mitteln und
ich muss dann weiter gehen ja okay wenn
man die das argument so betrachtet sieht
man sofort ein problem denke ich und
zwar das als ich gesagt habe war dumm
ist es plausibel dass ich keine dass es
keine untersuchungsbedarf gibt ihr habt
gesagt ja wenn ich alles weiß was du
wissen hast dann muss ich keine
untersuchung unternehmen also das war
mein atomphysik beispiel also das setzt
voraus komplettes wissen also nur wenn
mein wissen komplett ist vollständig ist
keine untersuchung benötigt
stellen sie vor sie sind ein bevor es
zum beispiel ist ein expert und für
antike philosophie die angeblich und
vielleicht denken sie ja diese hürde
müssen ist angeblich ganz schlau und er
wird über das ganze sommer soll das tor
fiel über antike philosophie erzählen
und obwohl ich selbst erst mich sehr
sehr gut auskenne in der antiken
philosophie
es gibt ein paar sachen
hin und wieder die mir nicht so klar
waren wenig glück haben sind das
abdecken also sie kommen und so hören
halb zu nur falls ich etwas
interessantes sage ja das ist vielleicht
das zustand von vielen die anwesend sind
will jemand sich identifizieren indem
diese niemandes mutig genug was
eigentlich weil sie wissen dass sie
gleich fragen stellen würde
und das wäre eine art untersuchung
jederzeit also sie würden denken okay
ich gehe zu der vorlesung falls ich fast
eine kleine lücke die noch bei mir
besteht geschlossen wird und das kann
man in anderen bereichen auch vorstand
also ich bin ein sehr guter atomphysiker
aber das mit der erfahrung mit dem
zerfall von radioaktiven elementen das
war mir nie so ganz klar ja
ist auch nicht so ganz klar ist ich
glaube ich okay also um das um das
siegel zu machen muss man annehmen dass
ich weiß schon wie heißt ich weiß
komplett
aber wie sie zwei gesagt haben
um das wissen machen muss ich annehmen
dass ich komplettes unwissen habe also
wenn ich weil sie haben gesagt das
problem ist ich hab wirklich keinen
schimmer sie haben nichts anzubieten in
richtung verständnis dieses denkt dass
irgendwas war wie mein beispiel letzte
woche mit irgend eines sinnlosen wort
also sind sie mir eine blaue also sie
können nicht anfangen weil sie keinen
wissen noch keine kein wissen haben
und wenn man es so betrachtet betrachtet
sieht man dass diese zwei spalten
eigentlich ungültig ist oder nicht alle
möglichkeiten abdeckt ist deckt so gar
nichts die wahrscheinlichste möglichkeit
nicht ab nämlich irgendwas dazwischen
nämlich teilweise hab ich wissen
also ich hab unvollständiges wissen über
mein thema ok und deswegen könnte man
gut sagen dass das ein streit satz ist
also dass das eher lästig ist war es was
voraussetzt dass die einzige
möglichkeiten die es gibt entweder
vollständiges wissen man muss entweder
vollständiges wissen oder vollständiges
unwissen haben aber das ist nicht nur
inklusive sondern sogar falsch weil es
gibt auch einen zustand des teilweise
tat teil wissens
das ist allerdings nichts sagte thies
lösung sage dieses lösung ist hier und
jetzt ist nur so gut ist dann dran sagte
titz
auch nichts
andere gegenstände sid
er lernt die ganze natur in der
mannschaftlichen zusammenhalt und die
seele von allen kenntnis gekommen
so stimmten nicht so dass einer der sich
immer erst dann ein
was die leute alles selbst aufzunehmen
ok typische botschaft sagte thies mir so
ein mann haft halten das westlichen
seien sie mannhaft auch die frauen
sollen man hat sein und man so nie
aufhören mit der untersuchung das ist
das was er dauernd satz in dem
sokratischen dialogen wie ich mehrmals
erwähnt habe am ende sagt ja immer ja
machen wir aber weiter und die frage ist
nur wie und jetzt erklärt er warum wir
so sagen zuversichtlich sein sollen dass
irgendwas davon kommt nämlich wir wissen
schon das was wir untersuchen das
problem ist wir haben es vergessen also
die idee ist die zelle ist unsterblich
wurde ob das geboren und hat deswegen
sehr oft schon gelebt hat deswegen alles
gesehen und weiß schon alles das problem
ist nur wenn man gebäuden wird verliert
man das irgendwie das wird übrigens in
den pfeilern thematisiert es also das
werden wir später besprechen vielleicht
sogar nächste woche nächste woche
besprechen warum es wäre das wenn wir
geboren wird dass wir plötzlich alles
vergessen
aber aus irgendeinem grund sind wir
jetzt in einem zustand wo obwohl wir
alles wissen wir alles vergessen haben
das wäre sozusagen als ob sie sie sind
unter dem eindruck oder vielleicht
fangen wir mit einem mit einem normalen
situationen an vielleicht hat jemand
zufällig vor vielen jahren floss viel
studiert sie sind zu jung vor vielen
jahren sind es war
zwei waren die zwei jahre lang genug
dass sie viel vergessen haben
okay das ist nicht gut genug
nehmen wir an sie sind bei dieser folge
das ist übrigens gut dass sie alles
aktiv behalten haben für zwei jahre
nehmen wir an sie machen hier wird dann
sind sie anwalt für 40 jahren oder so
was
und dann lesen sie ein buch über antike
philosophie ja und bevor sie das buch
öffnen denken denken sie ja also wenn
wenn jemand mich fragen würde irgendwas
über antike philosophie zwei sein könnte
ich nichts sie könnten höchstens sagen
ja ich glaube es war irgend jemand
namens klar ton oder sowas aber was er
eigentlich gesagt hat weiß ich nicht
aber lesen sie das buch und dann dauernd
denken sie ja stimmt ja ja weiß ich ja
dass haltungs und doch erzählt
schade dass er schon gestorben ist
in der zwischenzeit
und aus der liste gestorben deswegen ist
mein haupt also das was nicht wirklich
angst macht ist nichts zu sterben
sondern lustig zu sterben oder ironisch
systemen zum beispiel wenn ich
umgebracht werde weil viele bücher über
antike floss wie aus dabei in der
bibliothek und dann 24 bücher über
antike floss wieder auf meinen kopf und
bringen mich um das wäre wirklich
schlimm
man würde denken hast du gehört was mit
dem sind was soll eigentlich mit lustig
weil es eigentlich tragisch aber
trotzdem lustig oder also die sie sind
sollte ich da und daran erinnert von dem
was sie schon wissen sollte diese idee
ist
wir sind bei allen themen in diesem
zustand also alles was wir wissen können
ist etwas das wir schon wissen und
deswegen ist untersuchung möglich oder
lernen es möglich weil wir sozusagen
nichts nichts mit leeren händen anfangen
sondern mit das wissen was wir nur
aktualisieren müssen
man könnte dann deswegen sagen dass er
eine andere website es gibt also sagen
eine andere mittel lösung zwischen
überhaupt nichts zu wissen und alles zu
wissen man kann alles wissen aber nicht
aktiv also nichts präsenz sondern so
sagt sozusagen im hinterkopf könnte man
alles zu verfügung haben und das ist die
sogenannte anamnese lehre die wieder
und die gehört zu den bekanntesten
theorien die man bei platon findet also
mit der idee wäre und wie wir einen
weiteren sender sich hier übrigens denn
die ideen überhaupt nicht erwähnt
in dem ganzen dialog aber wir werden
dann beim feiern sehen werden ist die
ideen der in dem frieden mit der
anamnese lehre eng verbunden übrigens an
am nächstes das heißt nur nur das heißt
nur wie der erinnerung auf altgriechisch
deswegen sage ich immer alles okay und
dann kommt wieder eine berühmte szene
sieht es als jetzt wo sollte dies ein
beweis anbietet für meinen es sagst hast
du einen sklaven hier den ich plötzlich
als beweismittel benutzen darf
und die nehmen einen sklaven jung der
griechisch kann aber mit ausgebildet ist
also es sozusagen ein perfektes unwissen
das wesen also er weiß nichts am
relevantesten ist das immer ein
erkranktes aber weiß nichts relevantes
für das thema der untersuchen und das
thema der untersuchung ist mathematik
oder besser gesagt geometrie wobei
geometrie und mathematik sind nicht sehr
weit
es ist ein schwieriger
auseinanderzuhalten in der europäischen
tradition und was soll ich ist dann satt
ist wir haben ein quadrat und nehmen wir
an dass das eine länge hat also das sind
alle natürlich nix lang und dann fragte
er den laden
ob der sklave
sagen kann wie groß ein quadrat sein
müsste um genau das doppelte zu sein
also doppelte fläche und natürlich sagt
der sklave das was nicht richtig ist
leider und jetzt das raffinierte daran
sagte thies erklärt den sklaven dass das
nicht stimmt da nur dadurch dass er
fragen stellt also er sagt er gibt es
von sich keine äußerungen kein keine
überhaupt keine positive äußerungen
erster fragen würdest du sagen dass das
solltest du sagen das ist ja nein ja
nein die sind nicht immer ist nicht als
ob man immer nur ja sagen muss oder
immer nein sagen was er musste richtig
ja und nein beantworten
aber nur so ist es auch mit common sense
kann der sklave sehen relativ schnell
dass das dass diese zwei quadrate gleich
sind und deswegen dass es hier vier von
diesen quadrat gibt und dass deswegen
vier mal die fläche hat nicht zwei mal
okay hoffentlich kommen sie alle mit
system wenn die mathematik sofort testen
wird
sagen sie es mir und was dann
schwieriger ist ist zu sagen was die
richtige lösung ist was ist übrigens die
richtige lösung
wie lange muss diese eineinhalb nein
weil einhalten einer halbwegs mal einen
halbwegs ist nichts 2x ist es sonst
irgendwas ja
bitte ja genau wurde sechsmal express
amex ist also wenn x1 ist dann ist 2 die
länge und das ist natürlich eine
irrationale rationelle zahl wovon man
vielleicht entnehmen könnte das der
sklave wirklich eine schwierige aufgabe
hat sie hat ihn hat von ihm das
unmöglich jeverland könnte man sagen
aber durch fragen stellen sie fest dass
dieses quadrat richtig ist und das sieht
man eigentlich sehr schnell warum das
sein muss also wenn das vier mal ob das
ist dann da das immer die hälfte ist
also das ist die hälfte von das und vier
mal ein halbes 2 und das gilt in der
ecke und das ist natürlich wurzel 2 weil
ich meine die diagonal eines quadrats
ist wird zu zwei mal die länge von
dieser seite oder dieser seite also das
die lösung
das ist nicht sehr wichtig was genau die
mathematische aufgabe ist das wichtig
ist für viele schon einen punkt wobei
ich habe immer ein verdacht
jetzt habe ich irgendwo gelesen aber ihr
habt immer einen verdacht gehabt dass es
dass es wichtig ist dass die aufgabe ist
eine rationelle zahl irgendwie zu
begreifen
also das ist nicht ein was ganz
einfaches was hier begriffen werden muss
ist es was sehr bestimmt sehr
schwieriges nämlich irgendwie diese ihre
zahl zu definieren und das kann man gut
geometrisch definieren aber nur
geometrisch das ist vielleicht wichtig
oder relevant aber
ich weiß nicht genau was man darüber
sagen soll
das wüssten was mit fußball hat so
ähnlich ist wie es wissen
das teilt müssten was man tun kann was
man kann den ball für zwar nicht die
namentliche eigentlich
ja genau hinein die es gibt hier auch
einen historischen hintergrund zu wird
zu zwei nämlich dass die pizza korea
sehr entsetzt waren dass es diese
irrationale zahlen gibt es gibt sogar
eine legende dass jemand wirklich
bewiesen hat dass das der diagonale
rational rational ist also es kann nicht
durch einen druck das heißt blog oder
kann nicht mit einem bruch präsentiert
werden und es hat ein mathematisch
bewiesen
deswegen haben die andere peter ihn
umgebracht die haben ihn immer auf einer
schifffahrt genommen und dann über bord
geworfen
also es ist nicht ja sozusagen 1 1 also
diese dieses beispiel ist nichts würde
nicht beliebig ausgesucht und 9 liegen
werde
ein verdacht dass irgendwie ist die
tugend ähnlich wie eine rationelle zahl
aber genau wie ist natürlich schwer zu
sagen aber das ist eigentlich auch meine
vermutung okay aber wie gesagt also der
haupt philosophische punkt ist dass man
mit nur mit fragen jemandem zeigen kann
dass irgendwas stimmt nicht nur dass er
falsche meinung hat sondern was wirklich
der fall ist
und dann haben sagte thies nachdem er
das gesagt hat
und wenn ihn jemand öfters und in
verschiedener weise über dasselbe
befragen
so glaubst du gewiss dass er zuletzt
diese dinge nicht minder genau erkennen
werde als irgendjemand also es ist
scheint also zurück zu
also wir hatten vorher dieses bild
also das ist sagen die aufgabe zuerst
von falsche meinung zu bewegen zu
reparieren und von ab und zu wissen
und das passiert und von falsche meinung
zu bewegen zu operieren
das passiert auch bei dem sklaven weil
sind das erste was der sklave sagt ist
ich glaube die länge ist 2 mal die zwei
mal sechs also zweimal die länge
womit wir angefangen haben das ist eine
falsche meinung und dann durch fragen
zeigt socket hieß ihm dass das nicht
stimmt und die übrigens mitten drin
sagte dies zu männern siehst du jetzt
ist ja auch im april also nachdem er ihm
gezeigt würde das seine erste vermutung
falsch ist weiß der sklave nicht was er
sagen soll
und dann fängt es an ihm weitere fragen
zu stellen also mehr fragen und
angeblich wenn sie das richtig macht
also wie er sagt wenn du drin wenn ihn
jemand öfters und in verschiedene weise
über dieselbe befragen würde dann würde
das so gut wissen wie möglich also hier
sorge teasers die hoffnung dass seine
methode die sokratische methode und
sozusagen von vom staat von der
startlinie bis ins ziel bringen kann
allerdings gibt es hier
ein detail was sehr wichtig ist vor
allem nachdem man den ganzen übrigens
ist der dialog gut weil ich zeige dass
dauernd und jedes mal habe ich hemmungen
das es sonst irgendein geschlecht ist
weiß nur dass es gibt nur drei
möglichkeiten
wir haben übrigens gelesen
neben bemerkung er habe gelesen dass
heute dass das häufigste geschluckt in
der deutschen sprache ist weiblich also
gegen 40 prozent des umsatz tiefe sind
die also wenn man überhaupt nicht weiß
wo man die sagen
also das ist so sagen ich weiß gar nicht
aber ich sage einfach die allerdings
natürlich ist das also maskulin und und
masken ist übrigens dann haben wir für
einen drittel und das übrige ist es
nicht aber natürlich tief heißt es dass
60 prozent der zeit an dem ich sagen
soll
weil es egal was macht ja kommen sie mit
so so das ist so ist meine beziehung zu
der deutschen sprache also ich bin immer
glücklich wenn ich ein substanzieller
nehmen muss inter ziehen und dann weiß
ich dass ich sehr sehr wahrscheinlich
die richtige angaben über 50 prozent
ich sage einfach denn das ich sagen mit
dem so allen
nur für alle fälle für alle fälle gerne
zelle
das war überhaupt nicht gewollt es war
eigentlich sehr lustig
also dieser dieser dialog das ließ sich
ein bisschen anders
zum zweiten mal und es oft so bei platin
wenn man ein dialog das zweite mal liest
sieht man dass er irgendwas am anfang
thematisiert was dann später erst spiele
später relevant wird und so ist hier
also sagen pass sagt sorg hieß dass der
sklave auf dem weg nach gießen während
der betrag wird er bewegt sich von
falschen meinungs- zu wahre meinung
also man könnte jetzt sagen dass er
eigentlich das als schwester
zwischenstopp hat es ist als ob man also
man fängt in österreich an und fährt
nach münchen wollen das ziel ist berlin
[Musik]
falls es ein schlechtes beispiel
man fängt den haller berner an dass man
will nach boston
woher ich komme und zuerst muss man nach
washington dc wo sie keine ahnung haben
und dann nach new york und dann nach
boston und dies sorgt diese idee ist
dass jeder schritt kann man durch
befragung ermöglichen
aber es ist wichtig dass man zuerst
dieser diesen zustand von bäumen
meinungen erreicht und wie ich dann bald
sagen werde
gibt es eine stelle am ende des rennens
wo er zeigt das war der meinung zwischen
unwissen was sie das ist das ist und
wissen das ist natürlich wissen wo es
gibt so sollen in der mitte war der
meinung auf jeden fall seine idee ist
zuerst erweckt man diese ware meinungen
in der zelle
er sagt es wie ein traum also hat man im
traum man irgendwann irgendwas kommt und
dann wenn man immer wieder befragt wird
dann erlangt er nach wissen oder
erreicht den zustand des wissens also
dass das ist die lange stelle mit der
wiederholung und mit dem sklaven kurz zu
verschiedene auslegungsmöglichkeiten
diese langen passage wir haben gesehen
also sofort erkennt man dass es ein
problem gibt nämlich dass diese zwei
spaltung ungültig ist und ein haupt eine
hauptfrage ist ob das platons und
bewusst ist weil das letzte woche gesagt
habe das ist anscheinend oft der fall
dass platon erlaubt seine sprache auch
citys fehler zu machen und wir sollen
das entdecken
manchmal entdecken sogar die die
charakter in dialog selbst dass das ein
fehler war und dann korrigieren sie das
auch wenn manchmal an
nichts wäre so ein fall
das ist oft so dass verschiedene platten
forscher dann nicht die meinung nicht
teilen oblaten einen fehler gemacht hat
oder ob er absichtlich ein fehler drin
eingeschrieben hat damit wir das
entdecken also die frage ist ist es
fehler 1 feller soccer teams und männern
oder ist es ein fehler platons also eine
möglichkeit ist zu sagen dass natürlich
weiß er dass das eine falsche die chemie
ist könnte man sagen also phase 2
spaltung mal wieder erinnerungen eben
ein eine zwischenlösung ist ja wie ich
gesagt habe aber eine andere auslegung
möglichkeit und das würde vor allem von
genf ein vorgeschlagen eine andere sie
ist in orcs fördern konnte man
interessiert sie hatten darauf
aufmerksam gemacht nicht nur sie aber
das spielt eine große rolle in erde
auswirken
das war der meinung auch ein
zwischending ist weg gerade gesagt habe
zwischen unwissen und wissen also wenn
man irgendwas hier in der mitte tun will
die wahre meinung eine gute möglichkeit
vor allem wenn er sagt dass der sklave
zuerst war der meinung entwickeln muss
und dann später wissen
und dann sagt sie was das ich auch
letzte woche gesagt habe - und so katies
haben offenbar viele wahre meinungen zur
tugend zum beispiel sie wissen dass
gerechtigkeit eintrugen lässt oder
zahlreiche andere typen das können sie
identifizieren
sie können bestimmte handlungen als als
auch als tugendhaft erkennen
sie können sogar
bestimmte personen haus tugendhat
erkennen
oder nehmen wir zb diese liste die
männern anbietet also was ist was ist
die tugend einer frau es ist sozusagen
barfuß in der küche zu sein und wie ich
gesagt habe wenn man diese liste
vorschlägt also tugend habt ihr pferd
ist so tun hat kinder sind so thumann
hat dem menschen so sollte diese
bestreitet nicht dass diese
beschreibungen richtig sind dass er sagt
nicht nein nein so sind tugendhafte
pferde nicht
er sagt ja ja aber ich frage mich was
tugendhafte verständlich frage was die
tugend ist also durch du beantwortet für
mich die falsche frage
aber er bestreitet nicht dass die dass
die antwort die er gibt zu diesen
falschen fragen richtig sei sein und das
heißt würde man denken dass männer sehr
viel zur verfügung hat in richtung die
toten zu verstellen nur was er zur
verfügung hat ist nur war der meinung
also er kann zum beispiel sagen ja ich
denke das tugendhafte werde also
tugendhaftes ein bisschen komisch
verkehrt natürlich aber nichts aber
nicht im griechisch also der tag ist nur
dass exzellenz also ein exzellentes
perthes tugendhaft nicht so schlimm wie
virtual was ihn ein enkel stets
überhaupt nichts wert kann nicht virtual
sein also da haben aber vielleicht ist
wo würden sie sagen dass ein pferd
jugendhaft ist
wenn sie alt glichen werden dann schon
also ich würde ein exzellentes wert ist
zb schnell okay war seine wahre meinung
warum nur eine wahre meinung weil er die
tugend nicht definieren kann
und wenn er nicht einmal weiß was im
allgemeinen die tugend ist wie können
wir ihm zu schreiben dass er wissen über
tugendhafte irgendwas hat das scheint
sollte dieses problems sie seien aber
auf jeden fall sein dann empfiehlt das
platons schon an diese lösung denkt was
dann am ende des dialoges dann mehr
thematisiert wird und deswegen erkennt
er dass unser paradox nicht gültig ist
weil wir doch war der meinungen meinung
haben könnten und in dem fall wo die der
uns interessiert gerade jetzt nämlich
die tugend haben wir sogar wahre meinung
das problem ist nur wie werden wir wahre
meinung in wissen verwandeln
ja also das ist ihre lösung andererseits
hat also das ist die hält man die feinen
lösung ist gut weil es verschiedene
themen des dialogs zusammen nicht
sozusagen also ist es zeigt was die
beziehung zwischen dieser passage und
der passage die später kommt die wahre
meinung was diese beziehung werde nicht
so gut für feines dann zu erklären was
diese diese wieder wieder erinnern
anbieten soll weil man könnte denken ja
also solange ich war der meinung habe
brauche ich nichts nichts wieder zu
erinnern
ich muss nur meine wahre meinungen
irgendwie das belegen oder befestigen
wir dann später sagt und dann habe ich
wissen und deswegen sagt fein dass die
also sie hat sozusagen eine eine lesung
oder lesung des orts die wiedereröffnung
unter betonen will also sie sagt ja wie
der erinnerung ist nur da damit wir
zuversichtlich sind dass wir ware
meinungen von anfang an haben also dass
unsere ist sozusagen unsere intuitionen
relativ treffend sind und deswegen
können wir damit anfangen und dann
weiter gehen das wäre die rolle der
wiedereröffnung da wir alles schon
wissen ist unser instinkt sozusagen
relativ gut
das ist ihre auslegung eine andere sehr
weit verbreitete auslegung was wofür
übrigens fast überhaupt nichts spricht
aber hört man sehr oft das ist die idee
dass plattform ages ist also in mathis
muss also das ist die idee dass menschen
mit ein ein geborgenes mit angeborenem
wissen gebäuden werden
der grün wofür das so beliebt ist als
eine auslegung platons ist dass viele
philosophen heutzutage den atheismus
akzeptieren also ein gebäude das wissen
paradebeispiel sind für die soffin der
sprache zum beispiel james key die
denken dass babys sind sozusagen schon
mit sprachfähigkeit geboren also dass
zum beispiel an grammatikalische
struktur der sprache irgendwie in den
gehirn schon vorhanden ist und dann kann
jedes neugeborene baby einfach diese
strukturen für benutzen um die sprache
so erwerben
also leute denken gern das plattform
irgendeine art eine art autismus hat
andererseits haben wir haben mehrere
probleme mit dieser auslegung erstens
normalerweise ist es muss nur eine teil
erklärung unsere kognitiven fähigkeiten
also etwa an manche sagen sachen ein
geboren manche sachen nicht und platz
und sagt ausdrücklich das alles schon
vorhanden heißt also wir haben wir
können wieder alles wieder erinnern
also erstens passt das nicht sehr gut
und das andere problem heißt
denn da die ganze natur in
freundschaftlichen zusammenhang steht
und die seele von allem kenntnis
bekommen hat so stets nichts im wege
blablabla warum hat die serie alles
bekommen weil es gibt nichts wovon sie
nicht eine kenntnis erlangt hätte weil
sie so oft gelebt hat also seine lösung
scheint sie seien nicht dass alles so
sagen oder einprogrammiert ist sondern
dass man aus erfahrung schon alles
gelernt hat ja und das ist das gegenteil
von inisys muss also die idee ist man
hat schon zusagen in der vergangenheit
erworbenen wenn man übrigens wenn man
das überlegt sieht man dass es hier ein
problem gibt mit der ganzen lehre weil
er sagt ja wie kann es sein dass wir
über überhaupt was lernen
ja weil werde schon gelernt haben ok und
das hilft uns jetzt zu lernen
aber wie haben wir das damals gelernt
also wir also zum beispiel
sie kennen sich mit antiken philosophie
schon aus das wissen sie nichts aber das
ist deswegen weil sie waren schon bei
napoleon bonaparte ja dass sie sind
relativ groß oder dass das auszugleichen
was sie mal waren und napoleon bonaparte
das ist mir nichts dir nichts
das beispiel ist nicht so gut aber
nehmen wir an dass napoleon sich sehr
für antike philosophie interessiert hat
vielleicht stimmt das ist jemand hier
expert ja natürlich weil wie könnte man
so erfolgreich ganz europa erobern
denken wir an alexander der größe er hat
es dort ließ als lehrer
das sieht man was man mit einer
verlosung ausbildung schaffen kann ihn
abholen werde noch ein beispiel ich
wette dass julius kaiser war auch
sinnlich gut in der antiken etwas wie
ausgebildet oder fragen sie einfach ja
auf jeden fall
sie waren schon da probieren und sie
haben damals alles über ein digitales
wie gelernt deswegen können sie das
jetzt lernen
jetzt würden auch wieder erhöhen aber
wie hat napoli das gelernt das ist doch
keine erklärung des schied als nur ein
schritt weiter in die vergangenheit
das ist eigentlich ein problem für jede
auslegung aber es ist möglich würde
sagen es habe nicht so gut für einen
rassismus aus ich neige er dazu
mathis muss war erstens ich weiß nicht
ob das überhaupt ein deutsches wort ist
aber ich würde so schreibt also das ist
das englische wort und ich habe die
gewohnheit wurde die ich habe ich nehme
an dass alle alles was ein essen auf
englisch ist ein ismus auf deutsch ist
oder sein kann also hindert ismus
eingebundenheit wenn dieses wort nicht
existiert jetzt existiert es das andere
was gut an deutsch ist also ich erfinde
hiermit er finde ich dieses wort
sie wollen dabei sie gibt es können sie
in ihren enkelkindern sagen ich war
dabei als peter hanson sie wissen der
der so lustig gestorben ist
dafür ist er hauptsächlich bei uns aber
ist auch weil er relativ muss das ist
dieses sehr nützliches wort erfunden hat
und ich war dabei analysieren
da gibt es wie diese rede in heimlich
der fünfte von shakespeare
sie werden ihren kranken kindern sagen
sie war jacke
die nazis muss mein mein liebling meine
lieblings auslegung ist etwas anders
nämlich das ist zu sagen dass diese zwei
sparten ist doch nicht falsch oder
ungültig warum weil wissen setzt wissen
setzt voraus dass man irgendwas
systematisch und sehr durchgehend
versteht es ist nicht nur ja ich könnte
es in der straße wieder erkennen oder
sowas
sie muss es wirklich verstehen wir
können sogar an stadt wissen können wir
sogar verständnis über nutzen jemand das
griechische wort ernst nehme es gibt ein
paar sehr wichtigen artikel zu als dort
wie ist eigentlich experte für ein
ticket wie also sein artikel ist
natürlich auf englisch also herr
vorschlägt dass man statt epidemie als
motto über setzen sollen wir das mit
understanding über setzen also
verständnis
also ein durchgehendes verständnis des
themas und stellen wir vor dann dass wir
zum beispiel nur war der meinung haben
darüber also nur war der meinung zu
unserem thema haben
zum beispiel haben die wahre meinung
dass ein pferd tugendhaft erst wenn das
werk schnell ist das würde das werde ich
nicht einigen mit einem mittel zustand
zwischen nichts wissen und wissen das
wäre ein beispiel von nichts wissen
ja also ich glaube
das werde ich gut oder exzellent oder tu
wien hat sind typen haft sind wenn sie
schnell und stark sind und gesund und
oder was auch immer
aber ob ich das verstehe oder weiß
nein weil ich kein pferd wissenschaftler
bin oder weil ich keine tugend
wissenschaft werden also ich hab keine
zuversichtlich ich habe kein keinen
zuversichtliches verständnis für die
jugend oder verkehrt deswegen ist war
die meinung gar kein wissen ja und dann
wäre das problem wie ich aus diesem
zustand wo ich nichts weiß
in diesen riesigen schritt mache durch
irgendwas weiß also die man könnte sagen
dass immerhin ein tier andere lösungen
die wir vorgeschlagen haben war
teilweise weiß ich dass irgendwas oder
ich weiß ich hab wissen über p
aber selbst das wäre problematisch so
wie komme ich von nichts zu wissen
teilweise zu wissen ist auch ein problem
also ich denke was er sagen will ist
wenn ich wirklich mit nichts anfangen
also wenn es um wissen geht dann kann
ich nicht wissen einfach aus der luft
holen
ich muss mit anderem wissen anfangen und
deswegen gibt es ein problem wie ich
fortschritt machen kann
30 frage kämpfen haben
ok also die die es ist eigentlich meine
auslegung aber es ist sehr nahe zu dem
was damals gesagt in seinem buch so
platter und männern also die erste folge
war leicht die zweite frage ist ob das
über vorkommen kann
ja das ist eine frau die platon sehr
interessiert hat also er hat sehr
ambitiös wenn es um wissen geht also er
hat seine vorstellung von wissen ist
sehr fortgeschritten und er ist sehr
beeindruckt von wissen
so ist er dass er sich oft fragt ob es
leute gibt die überhaupt was wissen ja
es gibt einen einen anderen dialog
namens karl sorges argumentiert dass
damit jemand irgendetwas wissen könnte
muss ja alles wissen weil alles mit
anderen sachen verbunden ist und man hat
da den eindruck also entweder alles oder
gar nichts
diesen eindruck hat man eigentlich auch
in der politik also es gibt diese
philosophen die die ideen wissen oder
verstehen durchschauen wir und dann gibt
es all die andere leute also entweder
perfekt oder vergiss es
und man hat schon den eindruck dass das
ist wirklich ein alles oder nichts spiel
bei ihm erst mit wissen und das dass das
ist kein realistisches problem sondern
wirklich seine überzeugung
es gibt die leute die wissen und die
leute die nicht wissen nur meinung haben
und es gibt wirklich ein riesen eine
spaltung oder eine riesen lücke zwischen
diesen zwei gruppen und es ist eine sehr
sehr schwierige und grundlegende
philosophische frage zu zeigen wie man
von einem zustand zu dem anderen kommen
könnte
das thematisiert ja immer wieder in den
dialogen es kommt immer wieder vor nicht
hier nur hier in männern vor auch in
weiteren diversen werden um diese
auslegung zu es stark zu machen wollte
ich erwähnen dass sollte dies immer
wieder im dialog sagt auch nach dieser
passage er sagt ständig wenn wir wissen
erreichen wollen was wir wirklich
brauchen ist sonst jemanden der schon
weiß und dann kann er uns beibringen das
ding zu wissen also was wir brauchen ist
ein lehrer
wir brauchen lehrer die schon wissen
haben und nur dann können wir den
schritt machen also nehmen wir an wir
haben schon die demokratischen schritt
gemacht wo wir die falsche meinung los
gekriegt haben
und dann sind wir
in dem zustand von unwissen und die
frage ist wie kommen wir jetzt wissen
antwort sokratische antwortzeiten zu
sein
ich muss jemanden finden der dieses
wissen schon besetzt und dann kann er
mir helfen vielleicht durch fragen
stellen oder vielleicht anders aber ich
kann das wissen nicht einfach aus dem
nichts wollen dass sie das ist das
problem
und das ist ein sehr grundlegendes
problem und ich bleibe es auch ein
richtiges richtig dass das ein problem
ist als sie wurden was fragen oder
eine meinung kann das ungewisse nicht
geben ich würde und ich würde umgekehrt
sagen dass es keinen kein wissen geben
ohne meinung weil ich immer hin ich weiß
dass zwei +24 ist aber ich war
und das heißt dass ich meine auch dass
2+2 ich meine meinung ist schwächer als
wissen oder also alle die sachen die ich
weiß meine ich aber nicht all die sachen
die ich meine weiß ich zum beispiel ich
ich denke als ich behaupte ich glaube
ich meine dass alle bekannten könnten
die nächste us präsidenten wird also er
hat vielleicht sogar eine starke meinung
habe ich vielleicht nicht aber es hat
diese starke meinung und vielleicht habe
ich sogar recht vielleicht wird es ja
präsident werden aber ich würde zu geben
er weiß es nicht ich bin nicht sicher
aber ich meine dass man vielleicht die
unterschiede ist vielleicht der
unterschied vielleicht sicherheit also
meinung sogar wahre meinung setzt nicht
voraus dass ich sicherheit habe müssen
vielleicht schon das ist das ist
komplizierter als das aber das ist ein
guter anfang
ich werde dann merkte wahre meinung
wissen sagen weil es dann das andere
thema das wir heute noch besprechen
müssen wird es sonst jemanden etwas
fragen
gute frage
das ist genau das nächste was sind die
alu vorkommt dankeschön von volta später
das nächste was kommt ist an sorry sagt
typischerweise sagt wir müssen dann
weiterhin versuchen die teams zu
entdecken und dann sagt männern ja okay
okay machen wir aber zuerst kannst du
mir doch nicht sagen ob die tugend leer
bei ist also die also die letzte 20
seiten hat er überhaupt nicht
mitgekriegt weil es zusagen wieder am
anfang und sagt dann ja ok die tu dir
einen gefallen und ich schlage vor wir
gehen mit einer neuen methode vor das in
der literatur oder tor wird es die
metalle der hypothese genannt also wir
machen eine hypothese die hypothese ist
liebe these ist die tugend ist wissen
wir vielleicht warum sage die ganze zeit
so viel halb so viel über wissen gesagt
hat das ist übrigens sehr schön
also hier sieht man plötzlich platon ist
so toll hier sieht man ein grundlegend
eine sehr grundlegende überzeugungen
beim plan nämlich dass der piste mol ogi
und ethik nicht nur sehr verwandt sind
sondern vielleicht am ende identisch
also wissen zu wissen so besessen und
gut zu sein und exzellenter mensch ist
nichts mehr und nichts weniger auszu
wissen ja aber das setzt er hier nur als
hypothese aus und er steckt das folgende
vor
wir sagen nehmen wir das an würde daraus
folge dass die tugend der ba ist ja weil
alles was man weiß kann man lernen und
sich essen wir bei ihrer frage übrigens
als sie haben gefragt wie kann ich diese
leute erkennen wir können sie daran
erkennen dass die andere leute
beibringen können tugendhaft zu sein
sie können das so zu sagen über sie
können das vermitteln die von den eher
der tu wien vermitteln weil sie wissen
haben und alles was man weiß kann man
erklären antwort ist ja
der vergleich mit dem architekten
[Musik]
das und er versucht dann diese these
stolz machen genau in dieser weise also
sagt wenn wir überlegen sehen wir dass
alles was gut ist wenn wir handeln hat
mit wissen zu tun also wenn ich zum
beispiel geld ausgebe dann ist das gut
weil ich weiß wie man geld ausgeben soll
wenn man unwissens geld ausgibt dann
gibt man geld für falsche war zwar aus
zum beispiel nehmen waren ich versuche
sogar verzweifelt mein geld auszugeben
also ich gebe das für irgendein charity
so gut wie heißen die ich habe die
wohltätigkeit dankeschön zwar auf meiner
zunge speziell also gibt es für eine
wohltätigkeits aber ich tatsächlich
heraus diese tätigkeit ist in der hände
der mafia und die benutzendes um geld zu
waschen sagt sagen sie das auch weil er
weiß ja was ist da falsch gelaufen
ich wusste nichts das ist mein das
fehlende wissen was paar nicht dazu
gebracht hat das geld schlecht
auszugeben statt gut ausgeben
natürlich könnte es sein dass sich das
fg und sie verwenden das für gute zwecke
wirklich also dann könnte man sagen die
hatte glück aber um sicher zu sein dass
es wieder ihre frage übrigens und kann
sofort dazu zurück um sicher zu sein
dass das geld ausgegeben wird muss ich
wissen haben also das ist plausibel
und würde als folge haben dass die
touren leer ist wir wissen dass nichts
also wir wissen nicht ob die tugend
wissen dass das haben wir super these
gestellt wurden gesehen das was dafür
spricht aber was sollte sie sagt ist das
ist genau wie in der mathematik man
nimmt man was als hypothese und man
sieht was daraus folgt aber dann sagt er
übrigens dass das ist ganz allgemein
diese methode also die idee ist wir
wollen wissen ob wahr oder falsch ist
und deswegen machen wir als hypothese
ickx und wir wissen nicht ob es stimmt
aber mindestens wissen wie wir dass p
von exports also dann haben wir
fortschritte gemacht zu sagen wir können
sagen solange stimmt danke also unter
der voraussetzung es stimmt natürlich
könnte man dann das gleiche wieder
machen und dort unter der voraussetzung
y stimmt ex und dann stimmt dann kann
man weiter gehen
wir werden später sehen dass platon was
sehr interessante und als ob dies auch
machen sehr interessante philosophie aus
diesem bild weil die frage ist natürlich
was ob das dann einfach immer weiter
geht oder was oder wie aber für jetzt
beim gegner nicht weiter stattdessen
sagte er wir müssen unser unsere
hypothese testen
dadurch dass wir was aus p erschließen
in diesem fall
wenn die tugend lehrer ist würde man
denken dass es leute gibt die die tugend
und das scheint nicht der fall zu sein
sagte tsr sagt sie haben also mich in
meiner erfahrung
die haben dauernd durch athen gesucht
für leute die mir tugend beibringen
können und ich habe niemanden gefunden
heißt es das ist eine anspielung auf
diese geschichte in dem in der politik
ja also wo er alle leute ab er fragte ob
sie ihm die tugend beibringen können
dies die sind alle unwissend und
deswegen scheint es prima dass diese
these vielleicht doch nicht stimmt und
deswegen dass diese these vielleicht
doch nicht stimmt also dass das ganze
könnte sagen zusammenfallen
und dann haben wir eine so ein ein
übergang in die halle wo ein dritter
oder vierter wenn man den sklaven das
klagen kinder zurzeit ein vierter kommt
in den dialog line und das ist ein mann
namens anita die tus war ist ein
es ist wirklich eine person die in athen
existiert hat und war und der leute die
sagten verklagt haben also er war mit
daran schuld dass sagte thies umgebracht
wurde und er kommt rein und sagte so
sagt hier kommt anitas genauer exciting
für diese passage im dialog wie schön
und dann sagt anita reith hast du bist
sehr schlau
vielleicht kannst du uns sagen und von
wenig die tugend erwerben könnte und
er sagt sollte sagt soll ich das
vielleicht etwa von den solisten nehmen
weil sie ist ein angeblich so weise wenn
er es sagt gottes willen nein nicht
diese schreckliche zu rüsten
und dann sagt sorgte die ist es
eigentlich ganz lustig sind sagt thies
also du musst dann viel erfahrung mit
denen haben weil du so eine schlechte
meinung hast von denen meine alte sagt
coach ist will ich würde nie was mit
denen zu tun haben und dann sagt sorry
ist also du bist anscheinend ein
sauberer weil du kannst du wissen dass
diese leute furchtbar sind ohne was mit
ihnen zu tun
eigentlich also es ist ein
offensichtlich eine parodie oder eine so
ein angriff
diesen hat diese person anitas aber auf
jeden fall ist so socke thies sagt ja
wenn nichts von ihm zu küssen dann von
wegen sagt ja von gut bodenständige art
ihn natürlich
und dann sagt sie es ja also dass es
schon naheliegend aber wenn man überlegt
es gibt all diese athena die runden weil
sie so tugendhaft war
und wenn wir ihre ist zone betrachten
zum beispiel semesters peter kieß wenn
wir wenn wir die nachwuchs diese männer
betrachten können betrachten sehen wir
das ziel ist zum beispiel dass sein sohn
pferdereiten beigebracht hat aber nicht
die tugend die die die annahme ist dass
das alle wissen dass die krise so ein
depp war
und auch per krise soll also er erwähnt
all diese berühmte athene und sagt ja
irgendwie war die nächste generation
immer hoffnungslos denn das so ist also
wenn wenn diese leute die tugend haben
und wenn die tuba ist warum haben sie
all diese fähigkeiten weiter gelehrt zb
pferdereiten rede halten so aber nichts
zu tun
und dann sagt anita in deiner stelle
würde ich vorsichtiger
das ist sehr schön was er sagt er sagt
vielleicht in anderen städten aber erst
recht in athen ist es leichter leute zu
beschädigen als zu helfen
also man kann in athen wirklich ärger
kriegen wenn man so was sagt das ist
offensichtlich eine bedrohung
er bedroht genau das zu tun was er
später machen wird auf jeden fall jetzt
also ich glaube das ist sozusagen eine
szene die rohes fleisch einen teil
erklärung anbieten will warum die
athener sorge dieses umgebracht haben
also wieder eine neben und merkenich
sehr philosophisch aber ich finde hier
wirklich interessant viele platten
vorgeht weil er zeigt dass sie diese
wirklich auszahlt versucht anitas zu
empören
also er nimmt mehrere beispiele von
berühmten athen und was ist mit per
leeze sein sohn war auch so hoffnungslos
ja wohin man sieht dass ein ich das
immer wütender und wütender wird und
dann gehe weg und bringt die das
gespräch ab und ich glaube irgendwie
will klatten will platon sagen janitos
ist zwar wirklich ein also nicht ein
nicht sehr angenehmer typ aber
andererseits war es irgendwie ein mann
der
absichtlich diese leute provoziert hat
vielleicht alles für solchen gründen
vielleicht nichts auf jeden fall dann
sagen dann stehen sie sozusagen wieder
mit leeren händen
also das ist ausgeschlossen wurde
widerlegt das ist leider die typen gibt
weil wenn dann würden wir ja hier finden
und wir würden auch finden dass wenn die
touren lehrer ist das tun habt ihr
männer ihres ohne anschafft die tochter
können wir anscheinend vergessen weil
wir in sexistischen akten sind aber die
männer würden mindestens ihres sohne
tugendhaft machen
also das ist aus das steht in der luft
so zu sagen
und jetzt sind wir sowieso ein
wiederanfahren jetzt könnte man wieder
könnte man sich wieder vorstellen dass
platon dann schluss machen würde und da
ist sie seien okay jetzt haben wir keine
ahnung warum keine antwort gefunden aber
statt das sagt socke giessbach bin ich
blöd ich habe die ganze zeit vergessen
dass man nicht dass man das wissen nicht
haben muss weil es gibt sonst was wird
genauso gut ist nämlich war der meinung
die haben die passage mitgebracht aber
wenn wir das vorlesen dann fest dass die
restliche zeit auf dann als ein beispiel
glück werde ich einfach zeigen will nur
beweisen dass ich das mitgebracht habe
nimmt ein beispiel und das ist endlich
nach eine eine stadt namens larissa
gehen will dann ist es egal ob ich weiß
wohl dass er ist solange die wahre
meinung darüber haare
also nehmen sie an sie wollen nach
bogenhausen und sie denken sie müssen so
und so eine u-bahn-linie steigen
aber sie sind sehr uns vielleicht sogar
sehr unsicher aber sie haben also sie
sind in eile und sident mehr okay ich
versuche halt dann kommen sie nach
bogenhausen
ja und sie hat auch wenn es sie jeden
tag nach bogenhausen fahren würden und
wenn sie das sehr gut
also wirklich wie ihren eigenen namen
wenn sie das wirklich fürsten wussten
wäre es nicht besser wenn wenn es nur
darum geht nach posen und bogenhausen zu
kommen ich habe drogen genommen weil das
wort sehr lustig findet bogenhausen auf
jeden fall also sozusagen für praktische
gründe ist die wahre meinung genauso gut
wie das wissen aber ist es dann komisch
dass er ist das hier
also hier wie sagst du wer immer die
richtige meinung hat der sollte es nicht
immer treffen solange doch richtig
vorstellen und dann sagten mit männern
ich wundere mich wenn sich diese so
verhält weshalb dann doch die erkenntnis
um so viele hörer geschätzt wird als
direkte gemein wenn sie gleich so gut
sind und dann sagt sigrid isser ja auch
dabei werde ich zeigen dann sagt sorg
betis das problem ist war der meinung
sind wie die legendäre statuen von
deiters
also das ist ein magischer skulptur oder
künstler der diese skulpturen gemacht
hat die so etwa dass sie manchmal
weggelaufen sind die skulpturen sind
sehr wertvoll weil sie so schön und gut
sind aber man muss sie befestigen damit
sie nicht weglaufen oder man verliert
sie
und der punkt dieses vergleichs ist
anscheinend dass die war den markt waren
wahre meinung auch so ist also wenn sie
sich auch war der meinung verlassen dann
haben sie manchmal recht habe eben
manchmal nicht das ist ein bisschen
schwer zu verstehen
mein mann würde denken dass wahre
meinung war wahre meinung ist war und
deswegen wie kann es deswegen weglaufen
es ist schwierig und mit den mitteln die
wir in dieser passage haben zur
verfügung
ist diese frage nicht zu beantworten
aus anderen passagen können wir aber
eine vermutung haben dass er was er
meint es zum beispiel vielleicht gibt es
mehrere welche um das zu zeigen aber es
zum beispiel denkt er vielleicht es
könnte sein dass ich war eine wahre
meinung habe wie ich in dieser situation
handeln soll
aber wenn die situation sich verändert
ist die meinung dann falsch konkretes
beispiel es gibt eine stelle in der
polit er im ersten buch wo jemand
behauptet dass gerechtigkeit das
folgende sei gerechtigkeit ist
demjenigen das zu geben was man ihnen
schuldet also alles was man schuldig ist
soll man geben und dass es gereicht
und dann sagt sagt es ist okay okay das
klingt gut aber das typische was ist
wenn jemand mir ein arzt aus neid und
dann wird der produkt und mann umbringen
weil er jetzt im zustand ist nicht mehr
richtig im kopf
wer ist dein gerecht und arzt
zurückzugeben also die waffe
zurückzugeben
und dann sagt der andere nein natürlich
nicht also dass man könnte sagen es ist
zum beispiel ein mehr geld aus es werde
doch direkt das zurückzugeben
aber wenn man daraus erschließt dass man
immer zurückgeben muss was man schuldet
dann ist das falsch
also das ist eine wahre meinung die dann
falsch wird wenn man sozusagen mit
aufpasst
und dann sagt sockel ist etwas ganz
interessantes es sagt war der meinung
ist ein teil von dem was wir wissen um
wissen zu erwerben
das andere was wir wissen ist ein pias
logisch
das ist schwer zu übersetzen aber dass
es so was wie eine erklärung der ursache
oder ist oder vielleicht hätte man
einfach eine erklärung sagen aber das
ist die befestigung die also ihren
metapher mit den skulpturen das werdet
die befestigung die man benutzt um
sicher zu machen dass dieses datum nicht
weglaufen
es ist irgendeine app systemische
befestigung die man zusammen mit waren
meinungen nimmt um wissen zu haben
also war der meinung ist nicht genug es
ist ok man wenn man wenn man glück hat
dann kommt man auf die richtige antwort
in zum beispiel bogenhausen
aber um wirklich sicher zu machen dass
das jetzt die antwort auf jede frage
also um sicher zu sein
um garantiert die richtige lösung zu
haben musste man diese befestigung haben
damit die meinung immer zutrifft und
dann wird es wissen dass es sehr ähnlich
zu modernen technologischen theorien die
wissen als war der meinung oder
überzeugung schluss justice action also
die rechtfertigung definieren und später
in einen dialog namen des theaters wird
platin das sehr gründlich überlegen ob
das richtig ist
ob man nur die wahre wahrheit also
meinungsfreiheit plus die rechtfertigung
hat das ob das genug ist
und wissen zu definieren und er sagt
nein er hat auch recht
mehr so was für sein wie wenn ich wüsste
warum es hier richtig werde das
zurückzugeben
das ist ein eid service muss eine
erklärung also die erklärung ist warum
hier und jetzt so richtig
zurückzubezahlen ja aber natürlich um
das so haben müsste man vielleicht sowas
wissen wie was die gerechtigkeit ist im
allgemeinen
das war eigentlich der letzte punkt den
ich machen wollte wir können jetzt gehen
zu diese diese suche für definitionen
die definition werde vielleicht genau
diese befestigung also wenn ich wirklich
wird wissen würde was zum beispiel die
gerechtigkeit ist könnte ich das so
sagen als test benutzen um es ist meine
meinung wirklich stimmt in diesem fall
aber so lang dass abwesend ist
dann habe ich ein problem dann ist
besteht immer ein gefolgt dass meine
leute meine wahre meinung wegläuft und
in special meinung verändert also nur
wenn ich wirklich die ganzen lage oder
thema gründlich verstehe ist zurück zoom
ein punkt mit dem männer und paradox nur
wenn ich wirklich sicherheit durch
gehendes verständnis habe nur dann kann
ich wirklich sicher sein dass ich die
richtige antwort treffe die und die
klassische lösung die plattform anbietet
um das zu erkennen sind natürlich die
idee also die ideen sind genau die
sachen die ich begreifen muss damit ich
nicht nur wahre meinung habe sondern
auch wissen und das werden wir dann im
freiland säen und das werden wir ab
nächste woche ist besprochen
vielen dank